الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هي المنظمه
التي تملك فيها اسرائيل هيمنه ثابته هكذا
لخصت سابقا صحيفتها ارتس العلاقه بين
الوكاله الدوليه وتل ابيب في هذا السياق
يمكن ان نفهم انتقاد رئيس الوزراء
بنيامينه لمدير الوكاله رفع الجروسسي
ووصفه اياه بالشخص الجدير الذي تحدث
باسلوب غير مناسب فكيف تتعامل الوكاله مع
برنامج اسرائيل النووي نعود الى عام 86
الذي شهد اول كشف علني لبرنامج اسرائيل
النووي الذي بقي لعقود من السندبابيا غير
واضح المعالم في الخامس من تشرين الاول
اكتوبر من ذلك العام كشف عالم الذره
الاسرائيلي مردخ نونو عن وجود مفاعل
ديمونه
وهذا المفاعل بدا العمل عليه اواخر
خمسينيات القرن الماضي بمساعده فرنسيه في
موقع صحراوي يبعد عن مدينه القدس قرابه 90
كيلومترا رغم هذا الكشف لا تزال تفاصيل
برنامج اسرائيل النووي سريه للغايه الا ان
اسرائيل التي لم تقر يوما بشكل رسمي
بحيازه برنامج تسلح نووي ترفض التوقيع على
اتفاقيه حظر انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ما
يبقيها خارج اطار مطرقه الوكاله الدوليه
حسب اقرار كروس نفسه
بينما ايران الموقعه على الاتفاقيه تعتبر
واحده من اكثر الدول التي خضعت لجوله
تفتيش من قبل الوكاله
هذه العلاقه الملتبسه دفعت صحيفه كيهان
الايرانيه الى وصف جروس بالجاسوس واتهامه
بتسليم معلومات عن علماء ايرانيين الى
اسرائيل التي تنفذ عمليات تخريب وفق
المعلومات التي تحصل عليها حسب الصحيفه
وسبق للدول الاعضاء في وكاله الطاقه ان
اجهد قرارا طرحته دول عربيه عام 2010 يدعو
اسرائيل للانضمام لمعاهده حظر الانتشار
النووي
حمله التصويت ضد مشروع القرار غير الملزم
اصلا قادتها الولايات المتحده بذريعه ان
قرارا كهذا قد يعطل جهود حظر السلاح
النووي في الشرق الاوسط